[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nah
[Music]
six
a 3-2
but yeah
[Music]
mr. forward to catching your legs never
catch hey I just wanted to like tell you
that you know a lot to everyone that's
here my happy birthday
um did you know I want to be a
firefighter I was like I'm gonna be a
lawyer I'm getting them fight with fire
and I'm gonna have a black lab I will go
by Hanes t-shirts the over on my hands
they wouldn't burn that quickly if I
knew what being a lawyer like would it
when I was back listen I would keep the
fire bass guaranteed
[Music]
[Music]
final moment
don't stop one thing I didn't even take
into consideration when we were doing
this is how [ __ ] hungover I'd be the
day after I feel pretty good I slept
from really really well my head hurts
my body hurts I have like a cut on my
leg and I have no idea how I will go
this morning and remembered that I had
parked my car in a towaway zone in the
car got towed
anything else yeah don't do drugs kids
yeah that's a good one so I I think no
matter what enjoy everything in
moderation and don't get to a point
where you're being an idiot because that
as you can see it really really sucks
either way
[Music]